hello I'm gonna sell a critic guy
remember it so you don't have to well as
we come to the end of December we look
at our last Christmas movie
but today's moving over we come to our
last Christmas movie Santa Claus
the timeless tale with the tool man
himself Tim Allen yeah I can't wait to
see this wonderful classic again that's
The Big Lebowski what the fuck wait a
minute that this is a Tim Allen movie
this is something completely different
what is this from the 80 what the hell
am i watching I'm sorry I'm totally
unfamiliar with this film what else did
this director make oh great sadness
assic what right - Supergirl you can't
possibly direct a good movie after that
[Music]
yes it's the ever-growing cult classic
Santa Claus the movies starring Dudley
Moore John Lithgow and yes The Big
Lebowski himself David Huddleston
it's a strange bizarre little film that
promises to be odd and upward all the
way to the very end why is this movie
continuing together such a weird yet
growing audience well let's close out
December to find out this is Santa Claus
the movie so we opened in sort of a
Viking ish village where we actually
discovered the origin of Santa Claus oh
you mean we're going to talk about the
actual st. Nicholas and what we
historically know about him he's a bad
guy with toys we're running with it how
did you find time to move on Lucy he
makes time what can I tell you
his fixation he hasn't put out a week
session so Santa doesn't have all his
magic powered yet he's just a normal guy
who makes little carvings and toys for
all the kids in the village so he leaves
the set of Fiddler on the Roof and goes
to deliver more toys his Rangers start
to get weaker and have a hard time
carrying on you know I appreciate your
dedication but you may have to consider
the fact that you're fucking insane
I mean think our two living animals and
your wife that you are killing to make
this delivery I mean seriously who would
risk their life just to deliver a bucket
or better prize and the prize wheel huh
three stores tutorials and the tsunami
just to give you your Christmas gift
here Sega Genesis yeah hey I already got
one from you
we're going to take this thing or no
yeah yeah thank you thank you I mama
yeah very very grateful for that hat
I'll buy the letter and there we going
that's right that's right
can I get you anything while you're here
nope
all right yeah we'll see you Santa cries
Oh Oh Jess when it looks like the
Christmas equivalent of when the wind
blows suddenly a bright light appeared
bathing them in a heavenly glow clearly
they are dead the little elves come out
through the light so I used to turn
little loosely as one minute they're the
size of GI Joes and the next they're
just kind of short and they take them
into the magical world of the North Pole
what is almost there Christmas toys
waiting for you what have they got to do
with me you are going to give them to
your children you have all the children
of the world I won't live long enough
for that both of you will live forever
um I'm the only one who finds this a
little threatening at times and great
that these people did save them from
death but then they're like you know
right you deliver toys for all eternity
I didn't agree to this you will live
forever
I have some questions about all we could
throw you welcome the snow to die would
you like that better now right then get
to work late we're not paying you
anything so he comes across an elf named
Pat played by Dudley Moore his job in
this movie is to push his inventions and
make as many bad elf tonnes as possible
gives me a real spinning of our
confidence and we are conscious she just
needs a little elf control isn't it elf
explanatory I don't like Elfa Shawn I
mean Charlie elf Todd hasn't helped so
to help there else
well it's self-explanatory you know how
I miss MERS how they would replace every
other word with the word summer yeah
look let's just imagine for a
millisecond but that was remotely funny
a spell won't work
stinger have you ever noticed that
there's no female elves in this place
this is Klaw seems to be the only women
for miles around
your wife will also be our impregnated
elf queen high on nothing toy making
time so Santa Slade get ready to go out
on his first trip
but first the up it has to look right
please just must've true
what about chums red great perfect
keep everything yes you'll feel a lot
more cooked that way but before he gets
to a sleigh we get this thing ring
closure now two more degrees no my wish
[Music]
you
doesn't want to clue us in what the hell
just happened a bright light shines in
its nose they do nothing and then they
congratulate them so forth it's just
like the world's most excitable
weathermen and if you look at our five
day forecast you'll see that we get the
way
so just as Santa gets ready to go a
character simply known as the ancient
elf comes out to wish him good luck and
yes he is played by burgess Meredith
prophecy has come to pass that there
would come to us a chosen one and that
he having no child of his own would love
all children everywhere my god movie
whitened
oh Jesus doesn't get this must build up
in most Christmas specials from this day
on now and forever you will bring our
gifts to all the children in all the
world die why that I ate sprinkles and
crap made Christmas buggies how can I do
so much in just one night
time travel is with you Appy night of
the world is a passage of endless night
for you and look night eternal working
this job is sounding better and better
through the years he traveled around the
world gives toys poses in front of shadi
blue screens and soon all the children
know the name of Klaus I was wondering
if you would kill me today not today
back to work I hate my life you take you
people even start to write stories about
it he had a broad face and a little
round belly that shook when he laughed
like a bowl full of jelly what that's
how they think I look well in that
cookies hey trust me are you being
interpreted as a strong muscular Santa
is not everything is cracked up to be
but for all the good that's being done
Santa realizes he needs a
second-in-command
so he hires pests to run the place with
some of his new inventions to make toys
faster
[Music]
i've invented japan goseiger supports
patches attempt to put quantity over
quality that's the American Way and
later Santa comes across a little child
who seems to be homeless imagine out of
all the years he's been doing this he
finally comes across a homeless child
I guess he deserves special attention to
all the other homeless kids that don't
exist in this world but it's Christmas
Eve don't you know what that means yeah
I mean Java Jap til next year you'll
know rest of the winos don't you know
who I am I'm Santa Claus
right and I'm the tooth fairy well at
least I can tell if I'm a boy or a girl
I guess I'll just have to do it my way
Alec a child abduction holy cow how'd
you do that see what that done yet so
Santa takes him or her on the play and
shows off what he can do but then
they're suddenly spotted ru shim ru why
I hate it when this happens
Santa has to make sure that you have a
silent night but it turns out the girl
has must avoid at least I think it's a
boy he's cold jo though that could mean
Josephine anyway because she used to
leave food out for so Santa dropped him
off there for them to get better
acquainted but it turns out the toys
that patch made are all starting to fall
apart
patch of course watches in horror
Killman seven of defin your comment
comment something and in a bizarre
couple of scenes kids actually start
beating up the boy and girl because they
said they rode with Santa first of all
how do you know the kid is in line could
anyone say they rode with Santa second
if they do believe it why are they
beating him up he rode with Santa that
friggin awesome
guess what I flew with Superman oh yeah
what do you say deploy my dad without
anything an intersect I'm going in for
no reason
the girl doesn't have much luck either
everyone knows to stop shining super
toys my parents gave me a dollar
chicken's whole sentences I expect you
don't having a kid down there just
looking judo chop a kid also how do you
make the word our sound forth I don't
know but this kid found a way
[Music]
so what drugged-out Santa has to fire
patches his number two guy and I'm not
going to lie this is all really hard to
watch see how can I say this if you I
think that um
red red just just is my color
you know Oh mr. silver evidence a it and
gave up the job itself that is so sad
fucking thing I've ever seen Oh what now
he's leaving I take it back
this is the saddest fucking thing I've
ever seen could they make it any more
depressing than guys the reindeer are
crying
we've been cut the job let's go playing
the business head of a toy company
actually let me rephrase that
John Lithgow playing the alien from
third Rock playing the business out of a
toy company our drying comments he is
beyond over-the-top in this movie Keizo
Hiba making point mails and teddy bears
no I'm not kidding he pulled in the core
because he put nails in his teddy bear
how the hell'd you get nails it's like
baby bear it's not just a mistake you
have to make a concentrated effort to
make that happen the only thing more
complicated would be getting Sean
Connery inside of a barrel a label devil
he seems like the perfect guy for patch
to go work for don't you believe in
Santa Claus
why should I you never brought me
anything that's because you look
probably a naughty boy yes
I guess I was no angel so you know this
guy is a bad person and yet you still
want to work for him
welcome to Corporate America folks just
let me use your choice actually to make
what something special but to be fair
his business model could use a little
work what would it cost cost cocktail
are the people who who buy the toy
well nothing we're going to give them
away free oh oh that's when perfect how
do you turn your French Sorrento ha ha
you know I'm just imagining his acting
coach behind the camera giving him
advice okay John that was good but I
feel like you're holding back a bit
what's really out there besides I do
what I do okay here's the four freeway
let's go really subtle on this fucker
but let's go does finally come around to
agreeing and pitch make the magic candy
that can make people fly and he makes
sure just like Santa that every kid gets
one over the holiday
well the patchwork present comes from me
you'll find it under the Christmas tree
and best of all you will agree is that
is absolutely free
Elia your step up goal is just drop by
for a minute go in and wish you a Merry
Christmas
Stefan cool there's such a thing as a
step uncle is that sort of like having a
step friend Merry Christmas uncle it
certainly should be yes so let's go it's
a girl step-uncle seriously even still
trick doesn't recognize that word si
candy takes off like man which makes
patch think this somehow will get him in
Santa's good graces on strategy
but let's go has other plans what would
happen if you were to juice up the
formula they would make them slide why
you are some terrific else I mean I've
been busy I
converting since the machines to do
candy canes and in a week or two and
then I suppose can mostly ad campaign
tomorrow
strike while the iron is hot but as we
near to Christmas we'll bring it out on
March 25th
[Music]
Christmas cool we already have that
except the mess up are much more for it
typical Valentine's Day can we cut back
to the little boy and the little girl
okay seriously three years have passed
in this movie do they ever teach and it
turns out her uncle thrust by to reveal
his evil plan Santa Claus is finished
I'm taking over Christmas I next
December they'll be writing to me be
easy more paths Blue Ribbon in a brandy
glass dishes so let's go heard that
incredibly for sneeze and they capture
the boy they tie them up at the factory
when suddenly we find out that there's a
major flaw with the new flying candy
candy canes exploded they react to
extreme heat and turn volatile and got
millions of dollars pouring in every day
most of it in cash cash it stuff can
kill people you're going soft on me not
killing millions is going soft we'll
take the cash and let the elf taste the
music ah mmm that was subtle but it's no
before yeah so the girl notifies the
police and gets with cow arrested while
also calling Santa Vail but pass finds
the boy tied up and let them go fearing
the worst Tess decides to take his
flying machine filled with the candy
canes in the back to the North Pole but
Santa is on his way to stop them before
I blow so he pulls off the most
pointless of stunts that you can
and
what was the purpose of that why did he
need to do a look what a big more
density just stayed under them at the
same speed and then caught them after it
blew up god bless a useless Christmas
miracle can I say just till next
Christmas please and you can give her a
little time next year well to me if I
don't have enough to do now I'm going to
have to be a school teacher now we've
moved into kidnapping this has got to be
the creepiest North Pole ever bus of
film
[Music]
at least that would be what happened if
this all wasn't just a hallucinogenic
dream followed by death
hey that's not the real ending but let
it be awesome thrill that Santa Claus
the moon it's stupid it's corny and it
has a lot of slow moments but to its
credit
I didn't mire in a time I know that
sounds weird but there is sort of an
atmosphere to it and I actually do find
myself enjoying the actor who played
Santa okay he's not a traditional say
they don't have a deep booming voice but
he can carry a film pretty well the
silly moments are enjoyably silly and
even when it doesn't work you can still
feel the effort these people put into it
you always feel like they're trying hard
you don't want to fail so on the whole a
goofy movie so I'll admit I'm glad I saw
if you're in sort of an odd mood and
want to see a film that takes a selfie
tour to goofily or to seriously well so
this is the Christmas flick for you so
thanks for watching all throughout
December I hope you enjoyed it and wait
a minute next month of January you know
what that means
you
ha pray